well I would think that if they were  honest about it they'd start a major  investigation into the bite very simple  answer  investigate device because that is a  company that newly formed and global  companies in silicon and by the way  likewise China  the device what happened to China is  just about as bad as what happened with  with you brain so I would say that  president de Luci  I would recommend that they start an  investigation into devices because  nobody has any doubt that they weren't  cooking that was the crispy feel 100%  he had no knowledge of energy didn't  know the first thing about it all of a  sudden he's getting $50,000 a month plus  a lot of other things nobody has any  doubt and they got rid of a prosecutor  who is a very tough prosecutor they got  rid of them now they're going to make it  the efficient way but they get it so if  I were the president I would gently  recommend that